Si l'une de ces villes est à côté de chez vous
vous allez surement adorer il y aura beaucoup de rire je pense
Venez voir mon spectacle Norman sur scène
Que je continue en tournée dans pleins de pays
Et la vidéo qui suit est un best-of d'un live qu'on a fait il y a quelques jours sur ma chaîne Youtube
N'hésitez pas un mettre un pouce en l'air si vous kiffez, évidemment
vous me connaissez surement tous je m'appelle norman
Et si vous avez des suggestions, n'hésitez pas à commenter, j'en tiendrais évidemment compte pour le prochain.
et la soirée vraiment tres tres cool
on s'amuse bien aujourd'hui hein?!
on s'amuse très très bien
est ce que en régis l'ambiance est aussi bonne que sur le plateau ?
elle est très très bonne ! On peut faire un coucou au public aussi
[ applaudissement ]
Toi et moi depuis quelque temps on fait des vidéos ect
ouai
on commence à prendre de la maturité. On est fière un p'tit peu de nos vidéos
Un p'tit peu engagé. On commence à avoir un avis artistique un peu muant
oui
Voilà pourquoi instamment on a était dans un classement tous les deux parmis les humoriste préférés des français
D'après Mickey magazine voilà [ rire ] (Cyprien : "d'après le journal de Mickey" )
Cyprien :Ouai je l'ai même pas acheté putain merde
He ba moi je l'ai totalement acheté
Cyprien : je découvre hein désolé
On est quand même en couverture !! ( Cyprien" ah oui") heuu en tout petit
A côté de pikatchu quand même [rire ]
Entre Kev Adams et Pikatchu [ rire ]
Moi je me suis renseigné j'ai prospecter heuuu !! t'as acheté Mickey magazine
J'étais mon gas dans l'avion à Dubaï comme ça
J'ai retrouvé une vidéo qui était pas très dure à trouver puisqu'elle est totalement en ligne
ah oui d'accord
Notre premier featuring !! J'aimerai qu'on le diffuse s'il vous plait
Oh merde
J'ai trouvé cette vidéo
Est ce que vous voyez déjà (oh merde ) je me rencontre que mon visage n'a pas changé
J'ai vraiment un visage toujours de puceau
cheveux hirsutes et toi tu avais à la
barre depuis l'âge de 5 ans oui jury la
barge kinect de la barre est assez mal
et pas souci et n'a pas changé
non plus non plus il a vraiment changé
d'habits d'autres contrats roi toi
c'était notre une collaboration
musicale qu'il usait qui s'appelait les
bébés dans le congélateur
exactement sans cette vidéo ça on est
vraiment si tu veux partisans de bon
goût quoi alors je voulais simplement
faire à gagner un cadeau grâce à toi
d'accord ce que tu veux te donner du
plaisir aux gens
ah ouais c'est parti devinez le handicap
de cyprien hockey et il me up astigmate
hypermétropes ou impuissants voilà
vous réfléchissez un cadeau finale qui
est une sorte de téléviseurs hd avait
pensé que sont la caisse
ok d'accord une télé une une caisse
qui regrette pas c'était un truc s'est
dessinée oui j'ai ramené du petit
matos d'accord c'est riou andrade sorte
de feuille
ah oui d'accord j'ai eu un petit dessin
tu coules j'ai pas eu d'inspecteur les
couacs hommes comme comme des saints toi
tu veux qu'on dessine tôt enfin moi tu
veux pas alors qui d'autre
une proposition propane a dit une
compacte beaucoup trop la confiance
amusé de leurs intérêts de leurs
maîtres et les 3 oh my god
on envoie la musique du cadeau sa mairie
de venir faire un petit bisou à
supprimer
sur la bouche avec la langue est-ce
qu'on peut filmer les chaussures est-ce
qu'on peut filmer les chaussures de la
demoiselle est constament elle c'est
incroyable c'est des talons de 1 m bah
écoute et observe tech data du temps le
voilà qu'à l'afrique c'est très très
beau on peut montrer aux gens pas je
crois que c'est une sorte de mouton en
fait plus de ça tu as gagné quatre
places sur le pacte terminée soit a
perdu tellement désolée mais c'est
uniquement
est-ce qu'on peut mettre l'accent sur ce
dérapage et ses portes et quatre places
pour hausser partial pour le pack de sa
géniale
apparemment il ya un membre qui a
disparu oui tout à fait mr vie et n'est
pas là il est aux aînés aux concerts
de maitre gims abuser ça abusé il est
une voix on t'aime plus trop si le
questionnaire street kabylité ok vous
êtes des mecs les mecs du du route ou
pas est-ce que le uss et auprès des
gens comme moi trop en kahn est sorti la
première ermax enjoint aux gens de
canal 86 et fort ce que c'est presque
ça omagh à 87 ya une fille sur twitter
la et american qui demande à mettre un
peu de musique avoir tout domoun began
to work et jérémy pied réjouis toi
toi toi toi
c'est quoi cette musique à aa
ça va pas
citez-moi trois films de gangsters
américains american gangster attend le
parrain 2 3 alors qu elle a tout à
gagner la gauche ok et encore une
question a pu teint trop bizarre eux
écoutent thibault achète la question
autrement plus tard c'est c'est la bonne
ambiance et la détente
c'est ce qu'on appelle la drogue
quelqu'un est il capable de faire du
break parmi vous
devant tout le monde alors questionné
alors attention du semeur alors c'est un
blind test mais d'une seule chanson
c'est hyper rapide vous êtes prêts à
réagir pour le pentest 3 2 1 c'est
parti et je ne sais plus voir interrogé
on en a un là qui veut répond
asie ici au somail alors c'est le
premier extrait on va dire de le paix
que je vais sortir bientôt très
bientôt
depuis pas mal de temps j'essaye de
magazines et de son plein de sons pour
sortir un bel p et voilà on a commencé
à clips et je suis vraiment fier de ce
sont il est très bien reçu par les
gens je suis content que vous le
connaissiez merci l'a pas vu ça me
plaisait alors je sais que parmi le
groupe et à un deuxième chanteur moi
je sais pas forcément la taille décès
colette incroyable musique à la basse
et hakim on peut le dire tu as passé le
casting de la nouvelle star 2008
apparemment battu la rater tu as essayé
franchement c'est pour le geste c'est
beau en plus on van mais franchement on
remet ça pour rigoler en plus sont
vraiment bien alors le bien d'autrui
tant à faire gagner car et membre du
big bang qui n'est pas la question très
difficile
eh oui ilic bon bah voilà
écoute les dés sont lancés
mais je sais qu'il ya un différé de
deux minutes donc du coup on doit
attendre la réponse comme ça prendrait
pour cet été trouvé mais qu'il a
trouvé mister vie on peut l'appeler
qu'est-ce qui va gagner tous les cas si
elle a gagné des places de cinéma pour
mk2 c'est bien non c'est cool
des places de ciné je crois pas que
j'aurais rochelle toi
à temps ces femmes sont très très
belle le challenge est rien à faire
original et des mots sur plateau mariana
tant qu'ils sont pas là non mais on
pense fort à l on leur envoie des
bisous et franchement je pense que si
elle avait pu venir elle elle serait
venue avec joie car tu sais à quel
point nous t'aimons huawei
j'ai l'impression que c'est une
invitation et je vais vous le dire
beaucoup gens m'ont demandé
audrey si vraiment sortis ensemble qui a
dit oui les salons j'ai dit la vérité
et non bien couché ensemble déjà mais
je l'attends là où ne sortent pas
ensemble non on le dit officiellement on
le dit officielle du système ait des
chances pour tous les gars qui sont là
les vraies intentions la dalle mais j'ai
eu la chance quand même de te gifle et
à plaisir senti mal et a éclaté et en
fait on peut en parler puisqu'on est là
aussi pour faire ton live c'est que
norman qu'on appelle nous nono me dis
donc tu me met une claque
je suis dit ok d'accord avec juste un
joli chèque de meuf t'a beaucoup jour
parmi je pense qu'on en fait voilà donc
fait pour moi pas pourquoi pas tant ce
dernier montre plus tôt membres
eh bien ma soeur on peut en parler a pas
qu'une fois elle a eu des barbies j'ai
pleuré que tu le dis tu vois pas ce
qu'un garçon qui assume pas beaucoup de
messages de meuf qui s'en remet aux
étoiles et on change de sujet est ce
que vous gagnez un cadeau a et bien sûr
dans ce cas là on va tourner la fente
à roulettes qui lui rappelle sponsorise
ce live et c'est grâce à eux qu'on
peut offrir des cadeaux totalement
géniaux aux abonnés aux internautes
on tenait non non on en revient au jeu
mais bien mon pote à touba ça veut
dire quoi ça et bien et vient de gagner
et nos playstation 4 coupes un petit peu
voir chez toi tu peux le faire visiter
la voit pas vous voyez bien il ya une
pagaie attend explique nous ton délire
là c'est moi c'est pas un arbitre et
pas madame à mazères moi je sais pas
ce qu'elle va gagner mais tu es bien là
c'est le gros cadeau le boss le truc de
ouf à la gagne et ne put intérêts
regardez tous les types de cas madame
sans gêne l'arrivée sur le dans le
game a quand même temps ça fait deux
ans je pense ces jeunes hommes
en deux ans il a totalement percée dans
plein de films déjà raté deux cibles
de films c'est qu'elles jouissent ils
sortent en septembre ou en octobre
ça s'appelle le correspondant est
tamara d'accord j'ai un petit premiers
rôles voilà voilà
bien sûr tout ce qui est marrant c'est
que quand je t'ai demandé lanta chênes
toi même tu savais pas je ne connais la
stella beau ici voilà c'est pour ça
que je savais pas quoi mais lui c'est un
mytho 1 depuis et tu repars avec une
clio 2 200 km félicitations à ce que
j'invite les gens à s'abonner cette
chaîne ouais j'ai vu qu'ils avaient pas
encore beaucoup des bois non en fait
c'est la première on la porte 4 à
voler ta g nulle part tu vois on a fait
la vidéo a que nous qui l'avons vu les
mi-temps nous c'est un très très bon
choix de locations milk a cependant
parlé il trouve ça bien c'est bien
c'est un conseil a pas de rajeunir l
astee l abbé eux voilà ces deux mondes
la chaîne et vous cherchez l'un portant
sur paris on cherche à l'appartement
s'est passé ça enfin répondent au
hashtag trouver un appart à jimi was
his à la 3g une réponse ces demandes
à jawad
ok il ya des savanes et 1 victoire et
c'est ce qui est qui commence à se
poser des questions sur tarn signature
à norman est allé demande de faire dix
font alors allez mon nom et des pelles
ailleurs courte ensemble et la petit qu
un futur mal à à 2 330 le mans et
total 600 à chercher qu'on va chercher
va chercher chercher grand mère
incroyable les filles
si vous êtes intéressé fut là c'est
vrai il avait très très peur avant de
plonger la vue de ma mère je ne vais
pas moi il n'avait pas le choix parce
qu'ils avaient pépito notre moniteur de
plongée qui l'a pris par le bras a
vraiment bien ici
comment c'est un peu bizarre ce qu'ils
racontent voilà en tout cas on peut
voir le pouvoir le requin taupe c'est
pas des blagues mais vraiment heureux
qu'un oui bien sûr alors la très jolie
slip j'ai décrit j'ai découvert une
phobie aussi que j'ai mais parlons-en en
fait je suis vraiment cet homme a la
phobie de toucher la phobie de double
jeu là c'est moi qui fais le quatuor a
insisté alors que dans le désert c'est
n'importe quoi et c'est un sarcophage
qui te lâche dans le vide
il ya même pas de toboggans c'est le
vide tout de suite ça c'est mon corps
nul
une coupure aucun cette fraternité ont
ce tchèque avec un scaphandre c'est
quand même où c'est quand même assez
prouve que dans l'eau quand même mon
ventre au sort aussi qui touche kitab
voilà c'est un beau jour assez le fier
car aucun enfin la durée on dirait
plutôt une truite comment tu t'appelles
ah ouais je m'appelle antoine salut à
toi non je vois en toi tu penses qui a
plus de chances norman ou mois pour
tourner la roue tu préfères quelle
main chanceuse je préfère moorman
abuser allez je prendre la main droite
pour parce que c'est la main qui porte
chance
3 2 1 c'est parti on te met bien antoine
retrouver sur un put
au mois de mai que de la chance ce mec a
de la chance mais apparemment tu as des
écouteurs il faut donc c'était plus à
y faire
bah oui mais attends je suis reçue par
norman quand même passé quelque chose
toutefois il a écrit qu à la bataille
comme rachid rail mon pote
quelle force quelle musculature force de
frappe peut l'applaudir
laetitia tu es tombé sur force de
frappe ça veut dire qu'à force de
frappe du mot est bien vain de gagner le
playstation store aux réactions merci
beaucoup merci mille fois merci à toi
merci à toi tu est hyper gentil et on a
eu la chance d'avoir des artistes comme
christine and queens comme soprano de
charlie winston les casseurs flotteurs
the do louane voilà que dès que des
gens qu'on aime et des gens très
talentueux
c'est vachement bien ouais je parle et
se taper meuf on va vous faire deviner
des à des morceaux avec des instruments
un peu bizarre comme ceux qui couchent
ville vous savez qu'une pile
glockenspiel ah ouais c'est un mot
allemand un mois elle commence comme ça
s'entend qu est ce que tout le monde
appelle un xylophone mais non c'est un
glockenspiel
l'arabie neige bravo qu'elle était
musical sur le black album 1979 c'est ma
jolie et à béton exactement bravo
la main que là tout s'enchaîne alors
c'est génial
la bonne réponse toi tu peux bien
chanter avec lui tu veux
on va remettre les choses au point
commente andrea on te demande d'être
totalement bilingue
j'ai un bon gros morceau du punk à la
plage je te brosses de revenir dans dix
ans quand tu sera totalement bilingue et
merci d'être venus cheikh du ghetto
c'est bien merci andré acteurs patients
bref c'est un morceau un peu spécial
oui c'est un mashup gasquet mais si vous
savez que c'est un mashup genre dû
s'excuser
attends je veux dire te demander ce que
c'est parce que tu peux tu à malines et
moi je sais pas ce que c'est alors c'est
quoi un mashup et là tu m'as bien calé
parce que c'est totalement ça s'est
souvent les dj qui font ça s'est
souvent les déjections soit comme dj
zebra jeu sexy inna qui connaissent pas
dj zebra allez voir c'est super mais
très très bien ce dj celle de maxime
allais il est très beau ton casque et
c'est un tel accent du sud vient d'où
de suisse à ankara c'est l'accent du
sud de la suisse je m'entraîne et
reconnue au sud de la suisse
et je sais déjà
non j'ai traîné là ce genre de jeu
alors même pas eu un seul à des mortes
de morceaux c'est un temps gelé
non je connais la musique mais je
connais peu là on ne juge pas on y
perdrait sans vos mélanges et athéna
ch'ti spirit et n'accepte pas dire à
maxime c'est a galéré mais tu as
gagné quand même la gagner quatre
places de ciné vraiment cool on a
partagé des trucs avec tout le monde à
discuter sérieusement on a déconné à
délirer les genres gagner des cadeaux
j'espère qu'on pourra le refaire
j'espère que vous écrivez aussi les
gens du public
j'étais je précise un très très bon
public et donc gérer complices en
musique on sur un petit boeuf
ok je vois ce que tu veux faire
merci youtube merci au public
terre propre char
non mais
mais c'est très simple c'est papa
cigognes qui va dans la nuit deux mamans
cigognes et là il commence un petit peu
bas à faire des bisous ah bon putain
j'étais persuadé que ça se passait
comme dans la catégorie gang bang sur x
hunter
ah ouais